[Applauso]
[Musica]
Chi di voi è pigro alzi la mano
Beh dai
non sentitevi discriminati
una parte di voi è talmente pigra che
non ha neanche voglia di alzare la mano
e la pigrizia è maltrattata da tutti ci
si sente dire non essere pigro sei
troppo pigro in realtà però è un motore
potentissimo il più trascurato il
filosofo arari sostiene che l'uomo nella
sua evoluzione ha sempre cercato di
migliorare la propria qualità della vita
e migliorare il suo livello di Confort
Cercando di evitare il più possibile la
fatica e su questo mi trovo d'accordo
facciamo un esempio
l'escavatore l'escavatore è
semplicemente una macchina che scava al
pregio di evitare l'uomo la fatica certo
una volta l'uomo lavorava col piccone
stava più ore si spaccava la schiena
Però vuoi mettere risparmiare
l'abbonamento in palestra
torneremo indietro io no anche perché
durante le vacanze di Natale con mio
papà quando avevo 14 anni Ho provato a
lavorare a 40 gradi sotto il sole col
piccone vi devo dire che non è
un'esperienza molto bella secondo un
altro esempio
un robot industriale ha il pregio di
evitare l'uomo lavori di precisione di
fatica e sostituisce lavori che spesso
sono usuranti e pericolosi certo una
volta l'uomo faceva un prodotto
dall'inizio alla fine ma oggi con le
logiche industriali attuali questo non è
più possibile torneremo indietro io no
[Musica]
l'escavatore nei cantieri i robot nelle
Industrie fanno lavori faticosi di cui
l'uomo nel suo percorso evolutivo è
riuscito a sbarazzarsi
la pigrizia aguzza l'ingegno Sprigiona
quel guizzo creativo che si serve della
tecnologia per realizzare i suoi
escamotage per evitare la fatica
e quando noi ogni giorno utilizziamo
queste tecnologie le utilizziamo sia
fuori in ogni tutto nel lavoro
nell'ufficio ma anche nelle mura
domestiche per esempio quando voi nel
buio della vostra casa
chiamata l'assistente vocale per
accendere una luce non siete voi che lo
fate ma è la vostra pigrizia
perché spesso anche scrivere un
messaggio
diventa faticoso e quindi
la pigrizia e Sprigiona la creatività ma
in realtà è anche un motore potentissimo
per fare in modo che un prodotto è un
servizio attraggano l'utente per esempio
nel mondo informatico dove lavoro io Noi
abbiamo un sacco di clienti pigri che
sono quei clienti che
cercano di mandare al computer
dell'attività Come elaborare testi
ricordare cercare di fare progetti
grafici Perché non hanno voglia di farlo
manualmente Io vi faccio una confidenza
sono un pigro
orgogliosamente pigro
che però ha il vizio di lavorare troppo
e
quando io avevo 14 anni mi ricordo che
disse a mia madre che dopo le vacanze
sarei andato a lavorare dopo Scusate per
la terza media Sarà andato a lavorare
Poi ho cominciato a lavorare durante le
vacanze come papà e ho cambiato subito
idea e ho scoperto che la penna I libri
sono molto più leggeri di un piccone e
qualche anno dopo ho scoperto che il
computer è ancora più leggero ma questo
Ormai lo sappiamo tutti e diciamo che la
scuola per me è stata una perfetta e
soddisfacente alternativa
alla fatica per allontanare la fatica e
quindi grazie alla mia pigrizia che ho
iniziato a studiare e da lì che poi
durante questo percorso di studi ho
incontrato una persona per me molto
importante è una persona che poi mi ha
accompagnato nel sia nel percorso di
studi ma anche dopo quando ho iniziato
il mondo del lavoro ma ve ne parlerò
dopo
torniamo a noi
era il 1992
e io stavo facendo informatica
all'università e stavo facendo un esame
di intelligenza artificiale mi ricordo
all'epoca che preparavo gli algoritmi
poi mettevo l'input sul computer al
centro di calcolo dell'università e poi
l'indomani tornavo a vedere i risultati
questo perché i dispositivi e l'hardware
di cui disponevamo quella volta non
erano ancora all'altezza di quelle che
sono le esigenze attuali
torneremo indietro io no E penso di non
essere l'unico e vorrei tornare un
attimo al mondo del lavoro e farvi
qualche esempio una volta un operaio
stava 8 ore davanti a un alto forno
rovente per controllare la l'avanzamento
della produzione mentre oggi lo stesso
lavoro lo può fare tranquillamente
seduto dentro un pc Secondo voi lui
tornerebbe indietro
un altro esempio
una volta un operaio stava per 8 ore
dietro a un sistema di controllo qualità
in fabbrica per verificare che i pezzi
prodotti fossero corretti mentre oggi
questo stesso lavoro viene effettuato da
una Smart camera alimentata da
intelligenza artificiale rete neurali
Che auto apprendono e che consentono di
avere errori minimi Secondo voi lui
tornerebbe indietro
e vi devo
nel mondo informatico Dove lavoriamo noi
per esempio noi dedichiamo
parecchie ore a fare in modo che si
possa fare portare la trasformazione
digitale dentro le aziende e la fabbrica
dove anche noi operiamo
in realtà ci sono sempre più persone che
cercano di declinare queste tecnologie
digitali per fare in modo di fare meno
fatica mentre lasciano alle macchine
tutto il lavoro della fatica
e prima vi dovevano un'informazione e vi
ricordate quella persona speciale di cui
parlavamo prima che ho conosciuto
durante le superiori Allora quella
persona si chiama Massimiliano che oggi
è qua e con cui abbiamo costruito un
percorso di studi prima alle superiori
poi all'università e e non è un caso se
noi siamo ehm ehm abbiamo un numero di
matricola la differenza Io ho 25 0 21
lui 25 22 all'università e poi abbiamo
proseguito in questo percorso ognuno poi
ha fatto una sua esperienza
professionale diversa e poi nel 2001
abbiamo costituito la nostra società
Quando intendo nostra intendo mia sua
dei soci che sono arrivati dopo ma
soprattutto di tutti coloro che ogni
giorno insieme a noi lavorano per fare
in modo che
le tecnologie digitali entrano dentro le
aziende Massimiliano è una persona
analitica Io sono uno sintetico
ovviamente sono un pigro però nonostante
queste differenze abbiamo sempre cercato
dentro le tecnologie digitali questo
connubio per poter essere poi allineati
e portare avanti questo progetto insieme
e quindi
la pigrizia si
Sprigiona la creatività e se la
tecnologia è pronta ad accoglierla
allora l'innovazione è presto fatta
ma voi potete immaginare cosa avrebbe
potuto fare Leonardo da Vinci che non
sappiamo se fosse pigro se avesse avuto
il motore a scoppio o se avesse avuto
l'intelligenza artificiale
ma le tecnologie all'epoca Non erano
ancora pronte per assecondare il suo
genio visionario
i visionari sono quelli che sanno
ascoltare le voci dal futuro e le
prevedono le mosse dobbiamo far sì che
la tecnologia sia pronta per porsi a
servizio della loro creatività per
promuovere il progresso di tutti
[Musica]
Se vogliamo dirla tutta in realtà è solo
grazie alla tecnologia che noi
riusciremo a preservare e rilanciare la
virtù della pigrizia
adesso
Chi di voi è pigro
dai vedo già un po' di mani alzate in
più
Viva i pigri e Viva la tecnologia
[Musica]
[Applauso]